hello everyone and welcome back to round
four of this year's video World Cup
Vincent kymer defeated Magnus Crossing
yesterday in round one of their match
and now he needs to beat him one more
time or hold him to a draw to ensure uh
proceeding into the the the the fifth
round of the video World Cup and it's
not going to be easy as it's Magnus
Carlsen we're talking about and he does
have the white pieces now uh Vincent was
able to take him down yesterday let's
see what happened in this one not gonna
spoil anything unless you just enjoy the
show uh Magnus has the white pieces and
he decides to go for Pawn to E4 uh sorry
about that we have Pawn to E5 by Vincent
uh yeah Knight to F3 Knight to C6 and
now Bishop to B5 Magnus goes for the
real Lopez and yes you need to draw yeah
many were expecting the the Berlin
defense here but no Vincent wants a
fight and he goes for Pawn to A6 he opts
for morphe's defense gush up to A4 and
now Knight to F6 with Pawn to D3 and
Bishop to C5 with Bishop to G5 and now
Pawn to H6 and now now this should back
to H4 nothing new here all been played
before D6 and down uh there are some
games where C3 was played h37 on move
Knight to see threes and all the magnets
goes for the immediate to D4 and it is
now already as of move 7 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how
Vincent deals with this with e Captain
D4 Knight captures on D4 and now Bishop
to D7 uh interestingly you could also
decide to maybe just uh sorry to just
Castle here and try to sacrifice a pawn
because after Knight captures and pawn
captures you can't really grab another
Pawn so you can play like this for
example the bishop captures you can go
Rook B8 put pressure on the B2 pawn and
now even if Magnus ignores this place
Knight the C3 you can go Rook B6
challenge the bishop after the bishop
moves now you play Pawn to G5 and after
Bishop to G3 now Knight captures and D5
Knight captures and root captures on B2
and it seems like you've given a bit too
much to go for this for example castles
Bishop to E6 and not much to show over
here so instead Bishop to D7 we have
Bishop captures and C6 B captors of
course you're not going to capture with
the bishop since Magnus gave up his
Bishop pair Vincent wants to keep his
Bishop there so Knights the C3 and now
we have castles we have Queen to D3 and
now Bishop to B4 uh the the problem here
is that if Magnus decides the castle
Queen side uh which would uh definitely
will be a very interesting game now you
can do it right away because Bishop
captures on C3 and now if you capture
with the queen well you have to capture
with a pawn but if you capture with the
queen then Knight captures here and okay
your queen hangs but also the queen and
C3 hangs and then we have Bishop
captures Knight captures and c3b
captures and Rook F capture 78 and the
black's position is just much better if
not uh straight out winning so instead
after Bishop to B4 Knight the EQ by
Magnus now he is preparing the castle
Queen side so he wants castles on
opposite sides of the board it's gonna
be a a race Magnus will attack on the
king side Vincent and then the queen
side that's definitely way to play for a
win we have Queen to E7 putting pressure
on the E4 pawn and the Magnus just
castles Queen side so Vincent is playing
a little bit faster than he did
yesterday however uh Magnus is still a
little bit better on time it's one hour
and 11 minutes versus 52 minutes for
Vincent here in this position uh Rook
fd8 putting more pressure on that E4
pawn and the Magnus defends at Pawn to
F3 so now of course you know what is
coming uh g4h for G5 of course you will
have to move your Bishop at some point
first uh and here we have Queen to E5 a
very very tricky move because now if
Magnus um well you could go for
something like uh G Bishop G3 or Ponte
F4 but none of those moves are enough to
actually do something about the position
uh you can't rush this for example if
Ponte F4 which seems like a very nice
move look at this queen E6 now comes
Knight to D4 attacks the queen here
Queen to G4 and now you actually try to
mess a black spawn structure here with
Bishop captures and F6 you run into
Queen captures an F4 with check and then
the queen will pick up the bishop so
that's why you always play King to B1 or
King to H1 regardless of where you cast
so that's one way to go about the
position the other one is just play
Bishop G3 what about this well then
Bishop G5 check again and if Bishop F4
now Queen to A5 and now once Magna
starts pushing those pawns it's not
really a big deal Bishop to E6 comes
with the thread of Bishop characters and
A2 obviously once done and Knight is
eliminated you will play A3 and now
after Bishop to C5 Pawn to H4 and if
Rook 8 to B8 now you will play G5 but it
doesn't matter Knight to H5 and if
Bishop back to E3 now you just play
Bishop to C4 and black stalls all of his
problems as the bishop on E3 is
undefended Queen captures Bishop
captures again comes with the check King
B1 and now Queen characters on A3 as the
B Pawn is pinned so none of these ideas
actually work for Magna so he has to
figure out how to play this without
Bishop G3 and F4 and he does find it he
plays Pawn to A3 first and that's how
you have to approach a serious game of
chess so Bishop captures in C3 Queen
captures and now Vincent plays Queen
captures on C3 uh because uh well you
just don't expect Magnus to make a
blunder so quick right out of the
opening in in the second classical game
in a row but Vincent actually had the
opportunity to well basically straight
out win the game here he probably
wouldn't even want to win it he would
probably just want to draw the
eliminated magnets Crossing out of the
competition but feel free to pause the
video and try to find why this is so
winning while I give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh instant kill and for those of you who
just won't enjoy the show it is Knight
captures on e4 that's the move uh that's
how you do it and now how do you
continue well if uh uh Pawn captures
then Queen captures uh sorry about that
if phone captures Queen captures attacks
the Knight and the bishop and you cannot
defend both and if Queen captures an E5
first it's the same thing uh Rook
captures here and one spawn captures
Knight The Rook captures attacks the
Knight and the bishop a very very rare
tactic uh even Peter leko himself said
that yeah it's one that he has never
seen so far so even even tactics like
those exist Knight to C3 not real
characters on H4 Europe 2 Pawns of
course you are completely winning this
end game but the Vincent trusted Magnus
played Queen captures in C3 Knight
captures and now Knight to h7a trade
queens and now it's time to time to play
chess once again Pawn to G4 by Magnus we
have found the F6 and now Pawn to H3 we
have now I do a faith and Bishop to G3
just putting pieces on optimal squares
fighting against that D5 now the C7 Pawn
will be hanging as well so Knights the
E6 and excellent Square for the Knight
and also you keep an eye on that C7 pawn
and now Pawn to H4 by Magna situation
and the clock is 55 minutes for Magnus
and only 35 minutes for Vincent with
King to F7 and now Pawn to H5 just
grabbing more space on the king side
Rook 8 to d8 now preparing to
re-maneuver the bishop here and Rook H
the E1 by Magnus now preparing to double
up with rookie 3 Rook D3 or maybe Rook
D3 Rook E3 or maybe Rook D3 Rook e to D1
many possible double UPS here and the
Vincent doesn't go upon to C5 the idea
being that if a pawn comes to C5 then
you can shift your Bishop over to this
diagonal Vincent actually goes the
bishop to C8 and now Magnus just
continues with Rook to D3 and now Bishop
to B7 Vincent doesn't want to change the
structure of the pawns because he wants
Magnus that comment him he says I'm not
touching any of the pawns I'm not
pushing them
at least for now and the situation on
the clock 40 minutes for Magnus 23
minutes for Vincent and Vincent Magnus
was for Knight to B1 again you could go
for B3 you could play rookie to D1 but
those are all very committal moves the
Magnus now plays Knights to B1 uh well
sort of the to make Vincent lose time by
playing Knight to B1 he's saying I'm
gonna put my knight to D2 to B3 and then
to A5 and imagine the Knight not being
gonna be one imagine the Knight on A5 a
very tricky position for Vincent with
the bishop on B7 being so weirdly placed
so okay uh Vincent goes Pawn to C5 and
now Magnus plays uh not anything that
we've discussed so far he plays Pawn to
C4 he completely closes the center now
D5 is no longer an option for Vincent
ever and Aleco even uh called this A
desperate attempt uh for Magnus to
create something out of nothing so let's
see how this desperation works out for
him him with Bishop to C6 now comes Pawn
to B3 but Vincent of course is a very
very strong player uh hones in on the
weakness right away a rook uh to B8 and
just putting pressure on that B3 pawn
and now the Knight wants to come to D4
to put more pressure on B3 and C2 so
Magnus stops this bishop to F2 and now
we have Rook the B7 preparing to double
up on the B file and really put pressure
on magnus's Queen side Knight to D2 and
now Rook eat the B8 with Bishop to E3
and now King to G8 this is incredible
here uh the the top engine
recommendation is King G8 King to H7 and
then re-maneuver the Knight via the d8
square to F7 and then to E5 and that's
exactly what Vincent plays even though
he's below 10 minutes on the clock so
that's how good Vincent is in the End
Game King to G8 uh King to C2 now adding
another Defender Here and Now Knights
the d8 we're preparing to re-maneuver
the knight uh Pawn to F4 Magnus takes
away the E5 Square from the Knight and
also prepares E5 himself because then
this will weaken the C5 Pawn so
situation on the clock 26 minutes Magnus
8 minutes for Vincent and uh they still
need to make seven more moves in order
to reach time control so here Pawn to A5
uh trying to create a weakness here on
the queen side and the Magnus strikes in
the center with Pawn to E5 and now
Vincent drops below five minutes and
it's a very very dangerous territory
Pawn captures on E5 we have F captures
on E5 and now Knight
comes the F7 here you could also go for
A4 right away but then you run into this
tricky e captures and D6 business C
captures Rook captures and now if a
capture some B3 you have to play King to
C3 that's the the key move and okay you
black could Advance the pawn the B1
square is covered by the Knight and by
The Rook but it's uh incredibly
incredibly tricky position the Knight
Will capture at some point on B3 if the
idler Rook moves uh the C 5 Pawn will
fall all in all magnets will end this
very Asian being up not being able to
having a past a pawn and a past C Pawn
at some point so instead Vincent goes
Knight to F7 this is by far stronger and
now Magnus goes for Bishop to F4 just
waiting not pushing anything if you try
to force this with the captures on V6
and C captures and Bishop to F for Den
then A4 is very very strong for example
Bishop captress on D6 a captures on B3
with the check again you have to play
King to C3 if you play King B2 then Rook
d uh sorry Rook to D just wins there's
no way to defend the bishop if you move
the bishop you lose the Rook here so
that's why King to C3 is much stronger
than King to B2 and now after Knight
captures on D6 you will play Rook
captures on D6 and now let's say Bishop
to D7 you will put pressure on the G4
Pawn then you will capture the H5 pawn
and this is a easy counter play for
Vincent so of course Magnus cannot allow
this he needs the every move he needs to
increase increase pressure without uh
deciding anything so it's really a
marvelous way to play uh Bishop to F4
increases the pressure on the D6 pawn
and now Vincent has to start capturing D
captures on E5 uh the problem was if you
let's say play A4 and you allow E6
Magnus creates a pass Pawn here then you
are just well very very close to losing
this is going to be much much difficult
more difficult to hold this
uh so after Bishop to have four D
captures on E5 it's definitely the
correct way to play Bishop captures on
E5 and now Pawn to A4 Vincent not about
to be tricked by anything he finds all
the absolute best moves with Bishop back
to C3 by Magnus now the problem is uh he
will no longer allow the bishop to be
captured and The Rook is coming to E7
with uh well long term pressure on the
G7 Pawn so eight characters on B3 with
check King to beat you and now Vincent
needs to make two more moves to reach
time control uh he has four minutes to
do so and it's not that difficult as of
course he wants to play Rook d8 he will
not you know allow Rook D7 so basically
Rook the E8 solves all of his problems
and that's exactly what he plays Rook E8
we have Rook capture Sunny 8 Bishop
captures both players have now reached
move 40 and have been granted additional
half an hour on the clock but you know
it's such a complicated position an
extra half an hour isn't all that much
and Magnus wasn't uh low on time to
begin with we have rooked the D5 that
was the point of the the line you will
capture on C5 then you will play Bishop
to A5 Captain C7 and Magnus will have a
fast a and a fast C pawn and while the
past B3 Pawn is very strong it's just a
very strong on B3 you don't see it
coming to B2 anytime soon with Vincent
only having a light Square Bishop okay
there's a knight but you know they say
when there's a knight there's a way
sometimes there just isn't a way uh
Bishop to C6 Vincent finds the only
Contra play available to him Bishop to
C6 Rook captures on C6 and now Bishop to
D7 now he's saying okay if you go after
my Pawn I'm gonna collect on G4 and then
on H5 so Magnus plays Bishop to D4 he's
not gonna rush it with Bishop to A5 he
plays uh the the point is after Bishop
to A5 and Bishop captures and G4 again
uh the position just gets decided and
Magnus wants to avoid this then even
Knight the G5 can be played which
Shields the the H5 pawn and then if
let's say Bishop to E5 uh you will play
Bishop captures on H5 and okay then you
you can start pushing but now I've been
instant also has to connect the
passwords on the king side and the past
Pawn on B3 so instead after Bishop D7
Bishop to D4 by Magnus
a very very tricky move as you'll see
Bishop captures on G4 and now Pawn to A4
he's not worried about the C7 Pawn he
wants to start pushing the pawn right
away and uh Vincent finds the correct
idea Knight to G5 now uh he is
threatening to capture on H5 but Magnus
just placed Bishop to E3 he doesn't go
for A5 right away uh uh because uh well
if if A5 then Knight comes to E6 and
again the position just gets decided so
he needs to move the bishop First bishop
to E3 uh and now we have Knight the F3
by Vincent and this is again much much
better than capturing the pawn if you
capture the pawn then look at this Pawn
to A5 and if Rook the B4 which is well
the idea you want to play Rook to A4
then comes King A3 that's the problem
attacking The Rook rule goes back and
now A6 if Rook to A8 you're gonna play
Rook to A5 and now if Pawn to B2 there's
just no way to save the pawns we might
as well push it to dislodge the white
king now white is uh much much better
the pawn will go to A7 is going to be
defended on a dark Square then some
Rogue B5 Rook to B8 action it doesn't
lose by force the the position but it is
much much worse so Vincent finds the
absolute best movement that is Knight to
F3 which forces Magnus to move the
knight uh and the Knight is a key piece
attacking this B3 Pawn so Magnus does
burn some time but in the end he plays
Knight captures on F3 if you're
wondering but what about Knight captures
on B3 isn't this just a free Pawn yes it
is but it gives Vincent a whole lot for
that one Pawn for example Bishop D7 now
threatening Bishop to A4 not to win the
pawn but to win the Knight on B3 and now
after King day three You're Gonna Play
Knight to E1 now threatening Knight to
C2 check to pick up the bishop on E3
you're gonna have to play Knight to D4
to cover the C2 square and now look at
this Knight to D3 and what you play here
The Rook is under attack you have to
play Rook to B5 and give up the exchange
because if you don't then look at his
Bishop captures on A4 and if King
captures now comes Knights the B2 with
check and you will connect something
with something of course you you cannot
go
up the board than Knight captures and C4
check picks up the bishop so we might as
well go down the board and now Knight
captures and C4 check picks up the
vegetable it's a King Day 2 and now
Knight captures on E3 Europe 2 Pawns of
course completely winning so instead
after Knight F3 Knight captures and F3
was played by Magnus Bishop captures and
now Pawn to A5 but Vincent uh finds the
only solution to the problem and that of
course is Rook to B4 it's funny how the
entire game of chess revolves around the
B4 Square I'm sure you guys have figured
that out by now Rook the B4 uh if Rook
to B8 just to give you how how terrible
uh Vincent's position would be Pawn A6
and after Rook goes day eight Rook day
five and the black is in total two Swang
you cannot go uh to dfr with the King
because Rook F5 check picks up the
bishop you cannot push the pawn because
of alpha Bishop cannot capture because
the Rook defends on H5 there's
absolutely nothing you can do here so it
would just be a disaster for black so
finding Rook to B4 is a bit easier
because all of the other moves are just
that terrible so Rook the B4 was played
and now Bishop to D2 I've just realized
my camera is a bit lighter than usual so
sorry about that but you know it's the
move that matter not my face uh Rook the
A4 now putting the Rook behind the pass
pawn and now King captures on B3 with
Bishop to D1 with check uh only move for
Vincent doesn't lose the game King to C3
and now look at this we have Pawn to C6
uh Vincent tries to lock in magnus's
Rook so The Rook cannot move because if
you capture them real captures on A5 uh
it was just better to just play Bishop
to E2 and keep the tension on that C4
Pawn but okay King the D4 by Magnus and
now Bishop to F3 uh preventing the king
from going forward with Bishop to C3
allowing Vincent one more opportunity to
make a mistake because as Mikhail once
said give your opponent as many
opportunities to make a mistake as
possible you know go to the same
position as many times as possible just
you know drive your opponent insane uh
maybe he will make a stick and that is
exactly what happens here what the
Vincent has to do here is Play Bishop B2
the only move that doesn't lose because
it ties the rook and the King to the
defense of the C4 pawn and now even if
real characters on C6 King F7 now the
king comes back into the game and if
Rook back to C5 then G5 also will give
Vincent a pass Pawn on the king side so
that's a pretty big deal for example if
Rook to C6 you will just go G4 G3 and uh
Vincent has a sufficient drawing
material however after Bishop to G2 now
after a long long time it is actually
Magnus Carlsen who is in a winning
position here feel free to pause the
video and try to find the only move that
wins the game for Magnus while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh really a brutal brutal move and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Rook to F5 made possible by
Vincent moving his Bishop from the
attack on the C4 pawn and now look at
this all of the squares are taken away
from this light Cori Bishop you can't go
here you can't go here you can't go here
and uh uh there are many many threats in
the position just to give you an example
a G5 which is basically the only Contra
play for Vincent uh loses terribly at
the age captures and G6 King to G7 and
now Rook F2 attacking the bishop Bishop
H3 you attack the bishop again Bishop G4
you attack the bishop again and now
after the bishop is defended now King C5
a nice Discovery here King characters
and King to B6 and there is no stopping
the a pawn as uh well the bishop just
has no way of helping out you're gonna
play something like Bishop to C8 but now
Rook to F6 with check King the G5 and
now Rook the f8 forces the bishop to go
back Bishop to E6 now upon this sorry
upon the C5 locking in this Pawn on a
light Square so the bishop cannot help
out with the defense and now the past a
pawn is just completely winning so this
is what Vincent missed he has to play
Bishop to H3 but it doesn't help the
Magnus plays the a very strong Rook to
F4 of course you have to keep an eye on
the C4 Pawn because otherwise Vincent
has drawing chances Bishop to E6 and now
King the C5 the pawn is sufficiently
defended Rook to A3 attacks the bishop
but now again like I said the entire
game of chess revolves around what
Square the B4 Square King the B4 forces
The Rook back King A2 and now King to B3
uh The Rook can no longer remain on the
a file Rook the display you would you
would love to play Rook to D2 to go uh
to d8 and then to A8 the guard against
the past pawn and also on E2 but your
Bishop is an E6 so you have to choose
between the Lesser evil and that is Rook
D2 uh played with only a few a few
seconds on the clock and here Magnus
just plays the A6 and here when he
pushed it he pushed the A7 and he
started nodding his head like okay
that's pretty much it it's merely a
matter of time before you resign uh
Vincent played Bishop back to age three
and now comes spawn to A7 we have Rook
the E8 this is our Magnus uh Vincent uh
fights against Ponte but now look at
this beautiful move Rook to E8
uh uh Vincent is uh I'm pretty sure he
wanted to resign right here because of
course if you capture them the pawn gets
promoted and by moving the The Rook away
from the f file now you can play Rook to
E7 once The Rook moves and that's pretty
much uh the only thing you have left I
think Vincent played Rook day eight with
like two seconds on the Clocky that was
granted some increment Rook to E7 and
now Pawn to C5 uh okay it will give him
access to the A8 square but it doesn't
matter now comes Rook the B7 Magnus
doesn't even capture on G7 I mean you
know tell the truth would you capture on
G7 of course you would Magnus even in
such an important game uh he doesn't
capture an unnecessary Pawn he just goes
Rook to B7 and he was in this position
on move 62 that Vincent kymer resigned
to the game as there is nothing more to
be done here uh whatever the bishop does
Rook the B8 like if you go Bishop to G2
then Rook to B8 check and that's uh of
course game over uh and even try Bishop
to C8 which will prevent check then Rook
to B8 again uh forces a resignation
because either you allow a queening or
you capture on A7 and then Rook captures
and C8 with check and that's a king of
seven Rook captures on C5 Magnus will be
up a full Bishop so of course completely
winning so incredibly incredible stuff
by Magnus uh just again creating some
something out of nothing this was uh you
know an absolute master class on how to
play in a must-win situation against
someone as strong and a strong as
Vincent kymer absolutely absolutely
incredible I I actually did not know
what to think I knew that Magnus was uh
well it was all basically depending on
which Magnus shows up the one that
squeezes every drop of water from stone
or the one that blundered the game
yesterday so it seems that the ones that
blundered the game yesterday also showed
up today as he did blunder very very
early on in the game basically still in
the opening but Vincent did not pick up
on that here on move 17 if Vincent had
found Knight captures on e4 then that's
it Magnus gets eliminated from the
eliminated from the World Cup but he
didn't and after that Magnus just you
know did his thing and he
played an absolute Brilliance of a game
so tough luck for for Vincent he had it
but he's gonna have to work extra hard
in order to eliminate Magnus Carlsen
tomorrow in the tie breaks we'll see
what happens then if you guys have any
other games that you would like me to
cover do you use heart attack suggestion
and I will go over them and yeah that's
pretty much it I hope you guys enjoyed
this a bit of a longer video but I mean
you you've seen the game uh so yeah once
again really hope you enjoyed this um I
would like to thank um I would like to
thank puru is the bestest wife Ayana
you're the best girlfriend my wife beats
any wife at chess Angus Cunningham and
Peter booth for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day